growth happens fast since we last talked
critter junction just bought another
gaming company
to enable cross-platform gaming now you
can raise virtual pets with friends on
pc
android and internet connected
calculators let's look at how critter
junction was able to quickly integrate
this new company's infrastructure into
their stack
when critter junction first bought the
new company there was one major concern
they had an entirely different cloud
provider and a different
architecture critter junction switched
over to containers and microservices
the new company's tech stack was a
monolith taking over the entire vm
critter junction uses a cloud native
approach the new company was hosting
everything on prem
critter junction really wanted to
acquire the new company to add its
cross-platform functionality to its own
offering
but everyone involved thought it would
take too much time and engineering
efforts to actually integrate
luckily critter junction called us
before they turned down this opportunity
to expand their offering
while still being able to scale and
manage diverse systems
we told them about google cloud's anthos
platform which lets you run apps
anywhere using gke
the idea is to provide a single platform
for managing
all kubernetes workloads wherever they
are
including on-prem and other clouds
this works because migrate from anthos
can turn vms and physical servers into a
kubernetes pod
which can run inside of a cluster just
like any other pod
once critter junction decided to go
ahead with this acquisition
they had a google cloud partner solution
team come
on site to help them set up a gke
on-prem cluster
and migrate over their newly acquired
company's existing infrastructure
next the team helped them set up a antho
service mesh
a fully managed service mesh to handle
communication between their on-prem
cluster
and their current gke cluster which
allowed the on-prem workload to be
visible
inside of the cloud console from this
point they could manage all their
workloads
in one place enable cluster load
balancing
and scale their services beyond a single
cluster or environment
originally critter junction was hesitant
to acquire a new company
even though it made business sense
because they were afraid of the risks
and complexity
of managing a hybrid solution but anthos
let critter junction manage the diverse
workloads they acquired from one place
without having to move them to google
cloud
they could migrate existing vms into
containers
get unified traffic management and scale
their operations and take on new
business opportunities
so that's a wrap for this episode of
season of scale
check out the link below to learn more
about anthos and stay tuned
to learn more about how critter junction
continues to improve the design of their
app architecture and dev processes
and remember always be architecting
[Music]
you